but another time my father he's dead  I stink the number one bus from Jersey  City Bergen to the high school and we  were on the bus one morning kids and  there was a guy reading a paper and he  had a connector of drool from his lift  the Daily News and there was a puddle he  was on heroin they would go to Jersey  City in those days and get methadone so  they would take the bus up north with us  so I'm sitting there he's passed the  [ __ ] out and there's got to be just six  inches of power this guy's been passed  out for 20 minutes I point my ass at him  and I lift up my hips a little bit I  kept my [ __ ] just pointing that even  if it wasn't boiling at him he would  ricochet off the chair and go straight  into his mouth he's sitting there I let  a fart go out and my little buddy's like  what yeah yeah well [ __ ] giggling I  should beat the [ __ ] this is what this  is why I hate people this is why I hate  when I repo guy give me a second  [Music]